Megan Fox is firing back at Mom shamers
it's mind-blowing yeah the 36 year old
actress posted this pic of herself on a
swing with the caption pick me energy
well the troll picked the wrong day to
mess with Megan because after they asked
where are your kids at she hit back with
a Savage response quote wait wait wait I
have kids oh my God I knew I forgot
something quick someone called a valet
at the Beverly Hills Hotel that's the
last place I remember seeing them maybe
someone turned them into lost and found
not really that hard to balance I feel
like I'm at home with my kids a lot but
the criticism continued another social
media user called out the actress's
reply a writing quote you know that's
not a good thing right Megan's response
a simple dear God you know I tell it
like it is but there was someone who was
into Megan selfie her fiance Machine Gun
Kelly his playful reaction quote you've
corrupted our swing whatever daddy said
the couple seems to be keeping things
light-hearted despite recently facing
rumors up a split but according to a
source the couple is doing really well I
think it's important to maintain
Intimacy in a relationship in the
distance it's very even with face times
or things like that it's it's difficult
to maintain a really deep level of
Engagement with a partner and so I try
to be there as much as I can quote they
both have been super busy work-wise and
personally speaking having kids of their
own they are naturally swamped on that
front as well
jumping
[Applause]
up next on their to-do list plan a
wedding yeah the couple got engaged in
January but they're keeping the details
of their upcoming nuptials pretty
tight-lipped listen how is the wedding
planning going I mean what's it like to
collaborate with Megan on this big day
on the on the wedding yeah oh we called
it off
you did no as for what we do know about
the wedding a source tells E.T Megan is
pulling everything together and has the
final say on what goes and what doesn't
quote they are both totally on the same
page they are so excited to spend the
rest of their lives together
[Music]